it is time for hatred mail and much like
what's going on in politics in general
hatred mail continues to get more
extreme and concerning if you've never
heard of hatred mail before this is what
we mean when we say hatred mail because
we cling to our guns and our God but
somehow totally cool with a billionaire
who wants to assault our wife patriot
mail written by Patriots who hate David
Pakman because America and because
freedom
today's hatred mail is horrifying I
don't know what else to tell you let's
take a listen to it and see if we can
make heads or tails out of it I used to
be left until I caught on to but it like
yours I thankfully only seen one video
of yours do you make us out to be idiots
you are what leads to hashtag hashtag
fake news you are joining into an echo
chamber of leftist Tabuk you come like
of as complete idiot
that last line aside this is actually a
really serious problem the problem of
projection from the right exists on many
issues as I talked about at the top of
the show today but on fake news in
particular it is a massive problem
because the right has very successfully
you know the things I give Trump credit
for are successful propaganda
initiatives and one of the most
successful ones has been the use of fake
news as a way to brand adversarial and
investigative news outlets and those
most loudly shouting about fake news are
actually the primary purveyors of that
fake news so this is a really serious
problem and it hasn't worked if you want
to anger the hate reott or to tell them
you're not going to be pushed around by
them use the coupon code hey treat for
tea when you sign up for a membership at
WWJ impact mancom you save 40% and 236
hatreds cry every single time you do it
and while you're on our website go to
david pakman.com slash serve
take a two-minute survey that will be
really useful to us in improving the
show and attracting advertisers that are
a good match for our audience